John you and will yeah everyone here is
on meth you and you and will our father
and son in this movie and I think a
great thing about your characters is
that you you kiss on the lips
father and son kiss on the lips in the
bill as often as possible and you do it
as often as possible that's right and
and and your sense was that you're it's
your characters doing it but that it may
be it certainly made their characters a
little squeamish yeah well I don't know
if it made them really swim it was
opposed to in the movie and it did
indeed I I entered coming down an
escalator I see my boy hurl myself into
his arms kiss him full on the lips I did
I liked it quite a bit you liked it you
enjoyed it yeah I was wiped insisting we
do it over he would gave us a lot of
smack we we sensed there was
uneasiness so we continued to do it yeah
even when the cameras were not rolling
when he he just kept teasing me about it
so I chased him all around the airport
threatening to kiss him I've never seen
him run fast I don't want to share you
with will
I want my all the time with you yeah
yeah that's there what are we gonna do
in daddy's home very and we run off
together yeah Mel we did you get in on
any of this you know well yes we had to
get on the action mark and I yes we
flossed you know what flavor of mint I
prefer yes very nice let's consider it
when actors take care of each other that
way
you